I told you this would be three weeks I'm
now committing to two weeks we're
delivering on our commitments the IRS
which I oversee within two weeks that
was secretary minuchin yesterday at the
briefing promising help is coming for
millions of Americans it comes as a new
monthly jobs report is out as of this
morning it shows that US employers cut
seven hundred and one thousand jobs in
the month of March as this pandemic
continues and virtually leads to a
shutdown of the US economy and the
unemployment rate that headline number
it jumped to four point four percent but
it may not paint the entire picture as
to just how many may be suffering from
this right now let's see how the markets
are reacting to all of it this morning
the Dow initially selling off its down
200 points here at the 10:30 a.m.
Eastern time now to bring in on all of
this is White House economic adviser
Larry Kudlow Larry good morning and
thanks for being here this morning
thanks I appreciate it yeah when it gets
first year reaction to those numbers
obviously this doesn't include two
months of March where we saw a virtual
shutdown of the US economy so what do
you think the actual unemployment rate
is in the United States right now well
look I'm not gonna guesstimate that I
will simply say these are rough numbers
a lot of people are suffering and I will
say the weeks ahead I think the numbers
are also going to be very poor this is
an interruption of what was a very
prosperous economy it's an interruption
from the virus and the necessary
mitigation efforts to deal with the
virus and I also want to say that we
have devoted enormous resources and work
with our rescue package to add cash and
liquidity try to keep individuals and
families keep them afloat keep their
small businesses afloat we've worked and
coordinated with the Federal Reserve has
never done before the total package as
you may know is 6.2 trillion dollars
that's about a third of GDP a third of
our economy that's how widespread and
that's it this is a historic effort in
other words it's tough I reach out to
those folks it's very difficult we're
doing everything we can
to deal with it and make it perhaps a
little easier we're trying to save jobs
save payrolls and save businesses so
that and this is maybe the key point
when this virus runs its course as it
will it is not permanent this is a
temporary issue as it runs its course
the American economy will be ready to
snap back I believe that's going to
happen well before the end of the year
that's a strong forecast it you know
Bank of America put out a dire note
saying that we're entering the deepest
recession on record they're talking
about three straight straight quarters
of contraction a seven percent
contractions thirty percent in the third
quarter another percent in the fourth
quarter so I know you're looking at
these economic models all the time Larry
and part of that is is looking at our
small businesses they're the engine of
this economy there is concern that some
of the banks that are going to be giving
these loans don't really know the
guidelines and that there's some
confusion as to how they're supposed to
administer those that is supposed to
happen this week so what is the update
on the information getting to those
banks well I I think the information has
gotten there I mean a treasurer
secretary munitions done a terrific job
overseeing a massive program we've never
tried anything like this three hundred
fifty billion dollars if you if you keep
your payroll intact a 1% loan and the
bank participation I mean look all
during the week secretary minutiae and
others of us have been talking to the
bankers and they came in with
constructive suggestions and those have
been incorporated into the plan the plan
begins today I guess and the application
should flow you have a wide I mean
virtually the whole banking community
will take part in this Federal Reserve
backed banks FDIC insured banks credit
unions everybody's going to be involved
it's not going to be hard and if anybody
needs to find out just hit the SBA
website and you'll get the bank closest
to you but I think this thing is ready
to
look these are government guaranteed
loans the banks know that we've given
the bank's a decent rate of return on
the loans and the most important part is
that small business folks applying for
the loans are going to try to keep this
economy going or at least you know keep
their employees attached to the business
that is so important that is the key
point in all this and I think the
resources and the execution going to be
very good so let's wait and see I think
the bankers are ready to play and I know
that folks need the help it would be a
huge help because this would allow them
to retain those workers pay those wages
pay the rent and the utilities and
eventually be a grant the way that it's
structured secretary minuchin to your
point just tweeted out I just got first
report on PPP loan the systems up and
running community banks he says have
already processed over 700 loans
processed for 2.5 million dollars but
what about those bigger banks Larry
JPMorgan told its small business
customers that it should not expect that
they're gonna start accepting those
applications this week still awaiting
guidance from the Small Business
Administration so when does that
guidance get to them because JPMorgan
that's one of the big guys we need them
part of this well look I can't speak for
JPMorgan I didn't know a thing about it
I don't know what they've been formed
III will say that mr. Brian Moynihan who
is the CEO of the Bank of America who
was an extremely prominent banker he has
been visiting with Stephen minuchin and
worked hand-in-glove on this and he's
ready to go so I can't account for these
big banks look the key point here is I
think the arrangements and the
adjustments have been made mr. minutia
has said were open for business on this
this is not going to be hard okay
eventually the banks will play look
Sandra let me make one additional point
it's not it's this lending program okay
it's the payroll protection but don't
forget don't forget we are putting out
six hundred billion dollars of
assistance and on top of the this
purchasing six hundred billion dollars
for individuals
for families for sick leave for
unemployment 175 million Americans
that's a hundred and seventy-five
million Americans will receive checks
and other forms of assistance it's the
most remarkable thing we've ever done
and we are working hand in glove
cooperating with the Federal Reserve on
their lending programs so fiscal and
monetary policy is working together this
dup net nothing like this has ever tried
before it's just you know yeah it's
going keep people going there's nothing
they aren't going right now so many so
many people have been laid off Larry no
I understand it's a massive coordinated
effort we get that but then you look at
the medical side of things and we're not
out of the darkest hour of this yet but
as the chief economic advisor to the
president you have to be able to start
looking at how you reopen the economy
once things do get better
so Larry final thought on that note what
are you looking at as far as a timeline
to get this economy running again well
look the first thing Sandra is really to
implement this phase three assistance
plan to implement it to execute it to
make sure it gets to all the men and
women and families and businesses and so
forth that's really priority number one
we must make it work I think we've
gotten off to a good start again it's
unparalleled assistance
the second point I'm going to make is
this pandemic and the mitigation effects
essentially interrupted what was a very
strong economic boom from prior policies
and you know the private sector come
alive now I say that because I believe
the economy is fundamentally sound if we
can end or close you know
gradually remove this interruption then
I think people will come back strong and
I think business will come back strong
people are gonna hear that and say this
isn't just a Larry people are gonna hear
that this isn't just an interruption I
mean you look at the cost of that
stimulus plan that we're implementing I
mean there could be years if not a
decade that it takes us to recover from
this that's why I'm asking you for some
sort
it's not just the economic op I just
don't agree I'm sorry Sandra I don't
think it's going to take years and
decades to recover from this we've had
health waves problems like this before
we've come back pretty rapidly I mean
again I think that's an important point
I may be wrong but I will maintain as I
think most people most economists
believe that this virus the pandemic and
the actions to mitigate it are temporary
and therefore the difficulties and the
interruptions I talked about that will
prove to be temporary our job right now
is to help as many Americans as we can
with this assistance so they can get
through this that's our job but I think
at some point it will be over it will
wash through the virus is not going to
last for years I just don't agree with
that and I frankly don't know anybody
that agrees that the virus is going to
last for years maybe we'll all be wrong
okay I get that but our thinking since
us is just to do the best we can to keep
people working to keep businesses alive
and therefore to be ready when the
shut-in recedes and we go back to
opening up business in this country and
use our free enterprise system which is
the best in the world so I'm afraid I
disagree with you I think this is going
to be tempted to be clear I was and to
be clear I wasn't saying that the virus
is gonna last for years the economic
impact of that and what that recovery
looks like but final thought on the news
of the day the unemployment number that
headline rate I know you've got to look
at your economic models and advise the
President on this I mean are we looking
at double-digit unemployment in this
country right now Larry final thought I
think in the in the weeks ahead Sandra
it's going to get worse
I can't pull any punches on that it will
get worse this is a very deep
contraction the numbers are going to
come in very badly they're going to look
terrible in the weeks ahead how much
longer I don't really want to forecast
that's up to the health people but
there's no question that it's going to
be bad there's also no question that we
are providing more relief and assistance
for unemployment than ever before in our
nation's history and
we have to do more we will do whatever
it takes that's what the president said
we will use all the livers and power of
the federal government to help folks who
need that kind of help do you and based
on what you see so far those checks
gonna get to the people who need them
the most in a timely fashion you you
don't have to look far reports this
morning all over the place that some
people won't get their checks till
September so how how fast will people
get those checks Larry well first of all
the unemployment checks from the current
law are going out right now
second point on unemployment labor
secretary jean scalia has put the extra
unemployment money $600 per person
he has given those funds to the states
and it's up to them to distribute we
hope they execute quickly in terms of
the direct rebates tax rebates checks in
the mail directly I think you're looking
at a couple more weeks as I said that's
the more or less 175 million people
that's the 1200 per person might be
3,000 per family so I think the next the
unemployment checks are being
distributed the plus up in unemployment
that might take another week or two from
the states but it's coming and in terms
of direct checks in the mail to help
people get through this that should come
hopefully in a couple more weeks so I
think it will be pretty timely it's a
crucial time for those people larry
cudlow really appreciate all your time
this morning thank you thank you
appreciate but you soon thanks